so romance is a big part of season six
how would you just oh there's definitely
a lot of romance in season six I
wouldn't say that it's elizabeth's off
the bat however Elizabeth has fallen in
love with a new character in Hope Valley
straight away and that is her baby
Oh baby tis the season to celebrate the
holidays in Hope Valley ET has your
exclusive first look at when calls the
heart the greatest Christmas blessing
it's gonna be like a breath of fresh air
check out gorgeous glowing Elizabeth her
beaming smile bright as ever as she
gently cradles her baby bump
of course Abigail is right by
Elizabeth's side both ladies looking
adorable in their chic winter attire
radiant in red there's rosemary clearly
feeling festive and fabulous joined by
some of our favorite youngsters in town
I just think it's so fun it's like
really exciting to see that and how's
this for hashtag friendship goals
Elizabeth and Abigail literally lit up
with joy doing a little painting
together I think the fans will find joy
in back get ready to celebrate the most
wonderful time of year with these
friendly faces when calls the heart the
greatest Christmas blessing airs
Christmas night December 25th at 8:00
p.m. on Hallmark Channel three words to
describe season all vyx uplifting tender
romantic oh we love I'm so excited we do
it's gonna be the best season yet I feel
that way